me and tom got on really well in real
life the harry potter cast is stacked
with actors who are even more talented
than we thought based on just how
different they could behave to their
character we've got 12 hp actors showing
off just how much they were really
acting i'm good as gold number one calm
cool and collected but not always
sorry what am i doing
while emma watson was nothing but
straight a's and model behavior in the
movies she had some flustered moments on
set
the slightest little slurp
emma was gone
honestly watson is the last person we
would have expected to be getting in
trouble with production and getting
fined for corpsing on set how much is
the red card
i just couldn't keep it together and
maybe her earliest hermione slip up was
accidentally breaking a prop while the
cameras were rolling number two broody
on the outside charming softy on the
we love each other inside from the very
beginning felt improved how good and
after he was considering off-screen he
was just a sweet boy always ready to
have a chat and a dance
yeah man i've been doing my sticks i've
been working my feet you've seen my feet
work for my first trick
he hated on the gryffindors for the
cameras but off screen he was the best
kind of pal
look at him
it's a hard life in it yeah number three
young people are scared of snape and
rightfully so alan rickman on the other
hand is a different story the laughing
was often and in fact sometimes rickman
was the reason for even more giggles we
like to swim
in the deepest waters he tried to keep
it together in the midst of a prank he
was part of but the goofy and silly
vibes were just too good number four oh
bellatrix why so serious okay well not
all the time helena bonham carter was
plenty feisty i thought she got to be
sexy oh yeah carter was rambunctious for
sure but in a very different way than
her character i better have you know
breasts these aren't mine i mean the top
bits obviously are aside from the teeth
this smile is nothing but sweet
okay sort of oh and the stumble we know
it's on purpose but anything other than
totally controlled grace just feels so
off-brand for bellatrix
number five he kind of is harry potter
except for when he's absolutely not i'm
a crazy angel
reserved and shy on screen radcliffe was
a chatty firecracker on set living his
best life i'm an angel i'm an angel
humble harry could go full diva though
feisty i'm just being nice to people
because you are filming me
number six the whole not having a nose
on screen and constantly trying to ruin
harry really gives us strong evil vibes
that was a great scene and i love
shooting the death duel
that was cool with daniel in the in the
big courtyard that was epic what
differentiates the two is the fact that
voldemort would never feel bad for
harry's suffering so he had to put up
with a lot from me
doing endless takes while he suffered
feeling his head looks very different
when he's just refines and while we
never saw it rave had a little secret on
set for most of harry potter underneath
the robes i have very nice carter belt
voldemort in a garter belt we'd never
have guessed number seven sure he played
a character who was over a hundred years
old but he didn't behave that way
michael gambin in fact could on occasion
be spotted tap dancing about the set
it's this lively spirit that made him
such a memorable dumbledore number eight
we were all for dolores umbridge being
taken care of by some centaurs imelda
staunton on the other hand well she
seems like a blast even maggie smith
seemed to dig hanging out with her
disloyalty
strict and villainous she's not silly
and fun all the way
yes
number nine is it just us or is the fact
that lucius malfoy has a kid really
confusing jason isaacs luckily was
looking forward to working with some
kiddos i've arrived
ready to work with children and he
wasn't even shy with his praise and at
that moment i thought that's not a kid
that's a 13 year old actor lucius is
harsh no argument here but the actor
wouldn't hurt a fly not on purpose at
least
sorry love number 10 vernon dursley
being jolly
we just can't picture it and yet we'll
do a tempo like that not only could he
be kind spontaneous musical and fun he
was also nice to radcliffe there was a
man and he was an
encyclopedia he knew the weight of the
moon to announce in the name of every
star that's a bit of a better family
dynamic for sure number eleven adursely
and fun no way we had great fun in this
room fiona shaw had way more fun and was
much more pleasant to be around when she
wasn't playing petunia funny kind and
helpful we all helped because there were
thousands of letters now this is a
dursley we dig
number 12. we're fans of ian hart
professor quirrell not so much he gave
us the creeps when we were younger but
fortunately off-screen he was a chill
fun dude didn't you shave this morning
i did
you show me
his friendly nature is so out of
character but we're not complaining
these actors were not short of talent
some played their characters so well we
never would have guessed they were so
different in real life which actor were
you most surprised by